las autoridades libanesas prometieron
que en cinco días se esclarecerán los
hechos de la investigación por la
explosión del puerto de beirut del 4 de
agosto que acabó con la vida de 200
personas y destrozó media ciudad pero
seis meses después los libaneses se
siguen preguntando qué es lo que ocurrió
y ninguno de los responsables ha rendido
cuentas ante la justicia es por eso que
hoy cientos de libaneses han venido aquí
al palacio de justicia no solamente la
ciudad de beirut sino también en trípoli
y en sidón en solidaridad con los
familiares de las víctimas y para exigir
justicia la investigación está
suspendida desde el pasado 17 de
diciembre después de que varios ex
ministros pidieran la suspensión del
juez encargado de los casos para dif
aguas
hawas acusó al primer ministro en
funciones
hasan diab y a tres miembros de su
gabinete
de acto de negligencia ya que conocían
la existencia de las tres mil 750
toneladas de nitrato de amonio guardadas
en el hangar número 14 del puerto de
beirut pero el primer ministro no ha
comparecido ante el tribunal apelando su
inmunidad